hello everyone we will be starting with
workshop in a couple of minutes meantime
please feel free to introduce yourself
in the chat box please mention your
educational background and your research
interests
me
is
all right hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is shrek
krishna kumar and i would like to
welcome you all for today's workshop on
alpha fold and ucsf chimera to visualize
protein alignment so what is this
program all about we all know that
proteins are essential to life and that
knowledge of their structure can
facilitate an understanding of how a
protein works how to affect it control
it or even modify it
as a result predicting the 3d structure
of protein has been an important open
research problem for more than 50 years
but now biologists can visualize
unsolved protein structures make the
most out of ai's latest tools and
advance their skills in chem informatics
within seconds using alpha food that is
why we have designed the workshop to
introduce students clinicians and
researchers
to introduce them to alpha fold and ucsf
chimera to visualize protein alignment
as a part of this interactive workshop
you will be able to learn on how to run
alpha fold to predict structure from a
sequence search for alpha 4 models
molecular visualization using ucsf
chimera and finally a case study on
structural alignment and comparative
analysis
so before we begin with today's
interactive workshop let me briefly
introduce you to the team behind the
program
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy-to-use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
the omixlogic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world
this training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracks which includes
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis
so how do omics logic resources help
advance bioinformatics teaching
omits logic is a portal for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear part of the
bloom's taxonomy pyramid no matter what
the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omics logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like r and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
this program comes with an access to the
omixlogic courses which include courses
on bioinformatics precision medicine
multi-omics including genomics
transactomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that includes
using r and python
and even example projects of different
fields which you could learn from and
replicate for your research work
users will be given directions to access
the t by info platform for bioinformatic
processing and analysis of data the
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and analysis cloud
infrastructure to run the bioinformatics
pipelines different stages of analysis
are performed in different sections on
this multi-omics platform
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the omics logic plan portal before
that let me walk you through a brief
demo on what a completed profile on the
portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features you need to keep in
mind
that is a completed profile will have a
profile image full name with appropriate
capitalization link to your social media
handles this could be your facebook
linkedin instagram or kylie or even
twitter a brief about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and research interest
the mentor can view your progress under
the activity tab and the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the courses tab finally after the
completion of the courses the
certificates will appear under the
certificates tab so with that let us
begin by signing up on the portal
i am sharing a link to the portal in the
chat box
all right so i hope you have received it
just click on the link and i'll walk you
through the process behind signing up on
the portal so for users who do not have
an existing account on the portal please
click on the create an account option
that you see here
so once you uh
click on the create an option account
you will be asked to enter your name
your email id and your password
you also have the option to sign up
using any of your social media accounts
that could be your google account your
facebook account your
uh your app account your github account
or even your twitter so
i'll take i'll take brief uh pause so
that the participants can log in to the
account on the portal and once you have
done please put a yes in the chat box so
that i know i can proceed further
so i'm monitoring the chat
once you have
signed up on the portal or if you have
any technical queries please put them in
the chat as well and our team will be
happy to help you
all right i've got two yeses i'm waiting
for rest of the 40 participants all
right
[Music]
all right wait so if you have any
queries please put them in the chat box
and i'm proceeding further so since i
already have an account on the portal
i'm going to click on sign in
login login now option and click on sign
in
so
once you sign in you're able to view the
various courses and example projects
under the courses tab so please feel
free to browse through the list at your
own pace after the workshop
now once you click on the tab that says
welcome pack with your email id this is
the most important step that i discussed
during the presentation so how do you
update your profile click on the icon
that says profile and here you can
update your name link to your social
media handles and a brief bio about
yourself so under the activity tab the
mentor and the community manager will be
able to track your progress and once you
start taking any courses it will appear
under the courses tab so in my case i'm
completely i'm currently completing the
python course too and if you're
completing any projects it will be
uploaded here and if you're enrolling
for any of the programs you will be able
to view that here
all right so so far if anyone has any
queries please put them in the chat box
and i'll be able to guide you and with
that now i'd like to pass on the stage
to dr mohit mazumba who will be leading
today's interactive workshop over to you
sir
thank you srikari and hello everyone
okay
let me share my screen
again hello everyone and welcome to this
session um
i'm with i'm dr mohit mazumdar and i
have a phd in computational biology and
i'm an expert in computational
structural biology and i have several
publications to which i have worked
throughout my research and
industry career helping
some research groups and
during also my phd work so today we are
meeting to discuss uh and to learn about
some of the aspects
of structure prediction
so
as we all know and it would be great uh
if all of you can also introduce
yourself in the chat and and we can have
maybe a better
interactive session here um as i'm also
requesting that if you also have a
protein structure that you want to
protect in your mind and if you can
share the link we can perhaps take a
look at that also in the session so it's
an opportunity for those who are
actually doing something related or
would want to
learn about protein structure prediction
and
how to use the alpha fold and
more importantly uh what next after that
like uh if how to validate what would
have you predicted is this making sense
on or not
so please feel free
to share
those information you can send it to me
using direct message the protein
sequence of your interest
and we can take a look at that during
the today's session and
we'll try to be
trying to be i will try to do this
together and if you have those softwares
installed it would be great to
do this
in sync which would be to have at least
chimera installed so it's a
visualization software ucsf chimera
so if you're on
mac then you can use the x version
camera x which also has this capability
to
predict structure from the interface
which is incorporated in the macintosh
version mac version um and uh the
one that we have on the windows which we
will also take a look so i'm having i
have both the systems mac and windows
today i'm
using two logins so in case you face any
difficulties and you have any questions
feel free to ask
independent of the platform
now uh about the session um so alpha
fold
and alpha fold uh i think we've been
discussing this for a while and uh
uh also uh we have this ongoing training
program going on and i'm hoping that
some of the participants from the
program whom we are working with
throughout the sessions and mentorship
uh have also joined today's session and
we look forward to their questions
uh and in today's session we after this
wonderful introduction we have the
demonstration and some of the concepts
that i wanted to discuss about some of
the basis of what we are doing and what
uh is different and then we have also a
guest lecturer dr puneet i'm hoping that
he'll be able to join he's running he's
kind of busy but he he said that he'd be
able to join and answer some of the
questions that our participants have
going through his sessions during the
program
all right
so let's uh
start with that and uh
again
um yes sarah hi sarah
yeah we can try with your sequence it's
just that uh there's one limitation with
sequences again i should tell you this
that uh for predicting sequences of you
know
which are larger in size in length the
number of amino acids they hold
um is kind of
directly proportional to the time that
is it is going to take so usually
the predictions run on gpu and cpu still
uh because there are a lot of people
using this
so the prediction would take an hour and
sometimes more so we will go through
that entire process
and uh yes sarah we will have that so i
have worked on this on the on the
project
and uh we will schedule a meeting maybe
tomorrow or day after to discuss your
project and uh what are the other
the next things because i think it is
mostly about mutations and mutations are
so important
in in in the current era where we're
looking at the translational
[Music]
aspect by looking at
genomic data information and we're
looking at
the mutations and what are the
implications in the structure so alpha
fold is one of the way to look at one of
the snapshots but obviously today we are
going to discuss that what is actually
required to be able to make sense of
such a project where you are trying to
understand what would be the implication
of the mutation on the structure which
could be a single mutation which usually
will not cause any change major change
in the structure if you are modeling it
and just replacing one residue with
another but uh in in in folding and in
functional implication how that change
in residue can cause
the change in interaction network of the
entire protein and have a developing
effect or some
new features
so yeah
uh all right uh so as you know
alpha 4 2 and i am hoping that you all
are aware of what alpha 4 does because
we also have covered it at one of our
free webinars if you have not
then
you can ask that team to share that
video with you where we have also shared
a video by the team by alpha ford so
alpha four two uh
af2 was the star of casp 14
and what is casp14 it's the bi-annual uh
structure prediction experiment so what
they use is that they used noble uh
noble deep learning
and af2 predicted the structure of many
difficult protein targets at a near
experimental resolution uh so i hope
that you understand resolution when i
say resolution it means that
um
[Music]
what detail how much detail we got
from those experiments and
what level of accuracy in this country
in the context of alpha ford prediction
is the
is the closest to the native structure
and uh we do that by comparing
structures
and today we are going to learn about
that as well that how do we compare
structure what is the statistical
um statistical value that is important
to understand that how 90 percent
similar and how 80 percent similar what
is root mean square day aviation all of
that so
now coming back to the point where what
i was trying to say is that um that how
will the availability now
with alpha fold and other softwares
you have this option to predict so
predict structure of the proteins and
they are at a decent accuracy and
they're close to they say that it's
close to the near experimental
resolution so
now there's an availability of high
resolution structures how it is going to
impact biology
so first uh structure alone does not
provide the biochemical function of the
protein
nor can uh alpha fold to predict the
phenotypical function
which is often the result of complex
interplay of proteins so there could be
rnas there could be dnas there could be
metabolites um which
which could give us the complete picture
now uh that's why uh one of the key
steps for doing this is the first step
which is
to get the primary structure and then
from that three-dimensional structure
you try to model protein protein
interactions by looking at the complex
uh complex structures and the complex
interplay of
protein and dna and all of that so that
is one of the possibility to be able to
do that model further like move go one
step ahead with this uh with this
predictions
so another thing is that the structure
of a protein can used to enter infer its
biochemical function right that's one of
the objective but it can also you can
also perform virtual ligand screening to
predict which small molecules or drugs
it might be binding and and how it is
binding so that is again a session that
is covered in the last
last session where we covered a virtual
screening and uh software's involved in
virtual screening which are publicly
available anyone can start using them
download the publicly available data
from
game emba and other repositories and
look for similar structures and use kemi
informatics and then use uh
virtual screening softwares and find out
maybe top
1000 or top 100 molecules which you
would want to dive or go next
into with them using maybe talking or
other protocols
now um that's the strategy
usually for such
such
such research
now uh sorry for the maybe the image
below it's not coming high resolution
but uh
what i wanted to say is that even though
alpha four two can accurately predate
the
backbone
and the side chain conformation so here
on on the screen you can see that
um the
[Music]
typical confirmation uh with the all the
atoms which are uh which are forming the
peptide backbone and the different side
chain conformations so uh alpha fold is
kind of predicting
the backbone and the side chain
conformation
and it is for a particular
conformational state
why it is for a particular
conformational state because when you
crystallize proteins and this is based
on the available experimental structures
um that protein is another snapshot of a
conformational state however
a protein can exist
in more than one conformation it can
have one conformation in an inactive
state
and it can have another
another conformation in an active state
so if you have an active confirmation if
an active confirmation is predicted by
alpha 4 2 and and then
using it to target the inactive state it
will not work right because there is a
slight differences in the conformation
and below the image kind of shows
different confirmation of a maybe a loop
region in a protein and that itself can
change the
function of the protein and the
interface
and you know having
that multiple conformation allows
ligands to bind or specificity which is
very important in drug discovery and
drug designing
so prediction of protein structures or
where the
representation
using backbone dihatara angles that you
can see on the screen
has
really recently achieved significant
progress and that's why i was i was kind
of discussing in this slide is that uh
what we have been you know used to is
structure based predictions and those
predictions are based on multiple
sequence alignments and then
finding similar structures and then
modeling using them as a tem template
and that has been a common practice
using either modular swiss model and all
of that which works really well for
closely related proteins now uh the
recent achievements and this is where
everyone should know is on
the ongoing surge of a
deep neural network so
the deep neural network
in research in general has a huge
implications and has been used so widely
so today we are going to review some of
those aspects of how
the advancements have come up in deep
neural network and we um
and also we observed that that in the
protein backbone
angle protein backbone and angle
prediction research there has been an
overall overall trend to employ more and
more complex neural networks
so
instead like people are what people are
doing
they are
adding more features many of these
research groups they are adding more
features
that might add to more predictive power
to the neural network but then there is
this uh important aspect in machine
learning is that when you have
it could be argued that when you have
redundant features that could rather
clutter the scenario because
uh more complex neural networks
uh needed to be counter balanced with
the
with the noise so and this is a
practical experience that people from
machine learning has maybe experienced
that when
we use a lot of features then there's a
lot of noise that has to be counted so
from artificial intelligence and machine
learning perspective
prospective problem representation and
solution approach do mutually interact
and does affect performance
now that's the key takeaway now
a case study
thank you for sharing about your
current
degree and your interest
now
as we are discussing this as a
understanding that
how
the new
structure prediction softwares are being
used how they work so before we go into
the live session like the demonstration
the objective is to for you to
understand that what is the logic how it
works what are the advancements so
that's why we are covering this
and uh i hope that this is informational
now um
something new so on july 20 uh 2022 um a
chinese group a biotech firm called
helixon they launched this software
called omega fold i don't know if you
have heard about omega fold or not
um this is after
alpha 4 so the first computational
method to predict they they claim it to
be the first computational method to
predict high resolution protein
structures from a single primary
sequence
like also what alpha 4 does but this is
using a different algorithm so this new
study by this chinese researchers fills
a much encountered gap in structure
prediction and inches closer to the
protein
folding in nature so omega fold is a
protein structure prediction algorithm
that uses a protein language model to
predict structure
the algorithms the algorithm works
without multiple sequence alignments
alignments which means
it's faster because
alpha fold
and also works on divergent sequences
compared to alpha because it uses
multiple sequence alignment and uh one
of the reasons like uh if you compare so
unlike alpha fold omega 4 does not rely
on the msas and then omega fold
potentially
better suited for proteins that have
lower sequence coverage
uh
like because multiple sequence alignment
when you do may help omega fold uh then
uh because it it has that additional
information but it could work without it
as well so make up for can predict up to
like um at least almost four thousand
uh residues and all uh then about the
comparison and uh
this uh
the like understanding that what are the
different models that are available that
are really um at par on gasp the recent
cast
where there was a
competition and people are checking
accuracy so the new model developed by
helixon they claim to be outperformed
rosetta fold so another important
software in structure prediction is
rosetta fold
that is widely used and achieved similar
prediction accuracy to our alpha 42 on
the recently released structure so in a
study the researchers said that they
have used a new combination of protein
language models that allows them to make
prediction from the single residue and
uh this is uh by using geometry inspired
transformer model trained on the protein
structure so omega fold leverages a deep
transformer
based protein language model
that is trained on large collections of
a large collection of unaligned and
unlabeled protein sequences
to learn synchrony and pairwise
representation and used it as a feature
to model the distribution of sequences
now the omega fold the omega protein
language model which they are calling
plm can capture
using that what what this does like in a
layman's term is that it uses it
captures structural and functional
information
encoded in the amino acid sequences
through m through embedding
and then they later spread it to a
geofoam uh geometric inspired
transformer neural network to distill
the structural and physical pairwise
relationship between amino acids finally
they predict out of all of this this is
the kind of complex
but when you think about it in terms of
uh
in terms of
the features then it is actually not and
it's developed by research groups so our
objective is not to do this and like
develop something but to utilize it and
understand that how they are different
which tool to use when so this is a very
important aspect of you know
bioinformatics because thousands of
tools are
available online which we want to use
for your research and this varies from
you know problem to problem so this is
that's why biology is kind of
challenging so again that's what i was
coming at that this all of this
then finally they do a structural module
that predicts the 3d confirmation of all
the heavy atoms
another folding algorithm is called the
esm4
on the day it uses a large scale
language model for
protein prediction the improvements in
the language modeling
uh perplexity and the structural
learning continues through
i mean they have 15 billion parameters
just imagine that it's just because of
the
high throughput and this now
computational power this has been
possible through uh deep neural network
and that's what i was putting emphasis
on on comparing few algorithms which
uses deep neural network and like alpha
fold uses a neural uh network based
architecture and the training proceeds
based on evolutionary physical and
geometric constraints of the protein
structure so that's alpha fold and then
you learn about
omega fold and then esm fold and then um
rosetta fold uh so all of these folding
softwares
they are kind of comparable and they
could be used to you know if you're
working on a really important problem
you would want to uh take opinion like
when you visit a doctor you have
something serious you want to take
opinion from several of the doctors
similarly in in this case when you are
trying to predict the soft predictor uh
structure you would maybe
uh take a look at the other predictions
and then evaluate it which is the best
now this is the overview this was the
overview this was an understanding of
how we can maybe use multiple softwares
how they work understand and then use it
for
our own problem now in the last slide is
about the
um
the challenges
because one of the things that i was
discussing with sarah here is also like
you know
modeling mutations so mutation
uh protocols are a key tool in
computational biophysics for modeling
unknown side chain conformations so in
particular these protocols are used to
generate the starting structure for
either protein talking simulation or
protein
dynamics uh molecular dynamics
simulations so the accuracy of this
initial side chain backbone placement is
kind of crucial to obtain a stable and
quickly convergence in the context of
you know convergence comes in the
context of simulations so importantly uh
while knowledge of protein structure
alone does not provide its biochemical
much less phenotypical effects which we
were discussing previously structure can
be an important component of this the
challenge is to develop tools that
employ the more accurate protein
structure to infer molecular function
ligand binding protein protein
interaction and then integrate this
information with ai approaches to
predict phenotype
from genotype so that's the entire
picture and that's where we have these
several components which are important
so how inclusion of higher quality
structures improves the ability
to predict the drug side effects the
efficacy
and the role of distance variations in
non-mendelian diseases depending on the
accurately characterization of the
interplay between many molecular players
so these are some of the factors and
then clearly there is a dramatic
progress but more is remain to be done
with before the interrelationships of
protein sequence structure and
functional functions are fully
understood that's the conclusion of this
and that's where i think
the kind of
uh curiosity should be is that there is
a lot of things to do and there is a lot
of uh steps that are required so just
learning about alpha fold and clicking
and predicting the software and the
prediction is not enough the logic is
more and more uh important
and
then the
the kind of uh in-depth understanding
and that's why we are doing this and
that's why we are
we have this program and
[Music]
we as a mentor are trying to help uh
those who are working on this are
interested and looking at a career at it
to be able to achieve this within a
short period of time
and
maybe get the opportunity
now um now let's
get into the workshop part of things and
let's try to do this
by trying to look at uh how to
how to
start finding those uh
structures to predict and also like make
maybe take a case study
uh
and
as i said like if you have any sequence
of interest you can share that with us
and
we can take a look as well uh all right
i'll just stop uh the presentation here
but before that maybe i'll have another
slide
uh that tells you about you know
[Music]
a pipeline a pipeline which was recently
published by a group
they were doing a
program with students and
they made this workflow to find out
or to benchmark maybe some of these
methods
to find out if the structure
to go for a structural prediction uh
experiment
and if you're interested in predicting
structure and looking at structures and
its effects
um and do downstream analysis one thing
you shouldn't be know you should be
doing first is to know that if there is
an experimental structure which is
available or not
because obviously the most accurate
structures are the experimental
structures from where we have developed
these ai based models because all of
this works through machine learning
methods machine requires
to to learn
to and for you to make the machine learn
you have to give them which is
absolutely true or false and that's
where we have the experimental
structures so if the structure is
available or not is the first question
you should ask go to pdb
or do a
blast
and find if this
sequence of yours is available on the
uh protein data bank or not and
maybe we can try that step if you're not
aware of how to do that let me know in
the chat if you know from
how to uh maybe how to look for
structures uh which are crystallized or
have experimental information
uh first from the sequence information
just a simple blast that could give that
answer and if you are aware of it all of
you then i'll not take that step and if
you're not then i can show you how it is
done
after that
um
now uniproduct did a great great job in
the last couple of couple of years
uh integrating all the alphabet
predictions i think 200 million
predictions they did and that is
integrated in uniprot so we are going to
go into uniprot and check those
sequences
and the prediction and then um
then compare and one of the objective
was to do and learn about alignment
which we will be doing as well and then
um again the size of the protein is one
of the important factor here as i was
telling you because you can install it
locally and
then you have more computational power
that you're drawing from your own system
and not from the cloud because i think
the google collab supports the run for
two hours and then there's a paid
service that you have to take
otherwise you can maybe it's an open
source code and you can install it and
then you can try it on your own system
and run for
larger size proteins and maybe try maybe
fragments if not and if there are like
huge proteins and the templates
available then there's a possibility of
getting the structure full structure
full and structure of the protein
but in a protein sequence of that size
there are also unstructured
regions that are not well predicted
something that we will learn also when
we look at the uniprot entries
all right uh so let's uh take a look at
uh the practical aspect of doing all of
this and
i'll take a look at the
i will take a look at the questions if
there are any questions
how to verify the quality of the
structure what statistical test alpha
fold use
yeah
let's let me open that page for you and
then we'll talk about that
and uh alright sarah i have read that
what we can do to do this quickly
and there is uh
there is a protein structure is being
recommended by ankit pink one protein
definitely we can try this out check it
out and
even if we get the result um
later we can share it with you
and have a discussion around it
um
yes abdul we can predict uh vaccine
candidate structures we can predict the
three dimensional structure
uh h4 receptor i'm not sure we have to
look at
the
sequence
and then find out from the sequence if
the structure is available or not
if not then we go for prediction and
then we do comparison of what we predict
predicted versus what is uh
uh what is
is known
and then we understand the changes so
okay without wasting much time let's uh
start this and uh i will
uh stupa
shuba lakshmi yeah how can we compare
our structure from alpha 4 2 versus the
original structure pdb what matrices is
rmst
what others
perfect
good questions let's answer them through
practical
practical learning um okay now what i am
going to do is that i'm going to go to
windows
and i'll stop sharing
here
and
[Music]
then
i'll start sharing
my
windows system
okay
now can you see my screen
i think you can
alright let's open it
open a new
tab
and start this from the beginning and i
was kind of trying the new alpha fold
and
i got an error
which i was trying to solve
so you can
write this alpha fold collapse that's
all i've written
and the first link that comes in there
are two links one is
one is
advanced maybe another one is simple
when you have more
more parameters that you can
give for those who have done it like
several times they know about the
parameters they can change and play
around they can use the advanced version
you can start with the basic version
and
and this is how you go into this
now again um let me explain this to you
uh how this works um
so alpha 4 2
offers the option
to install the package with a docker
file or a honda installation script
so this is to run like on your system
and then both approaches are convenient
ways to install the packages both alpha
fold two and even the rosetta fold
packages comes in python so the rosetta
fold provides the infrastructure for
condyle installation so for these
instruction it is it is kind of
straightforward to build a docker or a
singularity image
it could be in your campus cluster
so uh alpha fold two
and uh
all of this maybe they'll typically take
with the protein databases
around three terabytes of space so if
you have that much space
you can have that entire system
installed with the
with the data bases and all
so
again um alpha 4 2 and
alpha 4 2 provides a python wrapper
scripts to run the prediction that is
what we are going to use in this uh in
this session
and the script expects
multiple input arguments that we are
going to learn
uh what are the input arguments the name
of the faster file the location of the
databases if required or the trained
models if you're putting it up
if you if you are looking taking the
advanced option
and then uh there are ptm and pl ddlt
scores
and
search path for
for software such as jackhammer or
msa for
using hidden markov so
you can do a lot of customization around
it uh if you
if you are aware of uh the
output of these algorithms and how they
work
now that's about it like an overview of
alpha fold uh collab so as i am was
telling you that this is all
kind of uh explained here as well
if you start from here
this is the database where we can search
the sequences of already predicted
structures and there is a lot as i was
telling you and
there was
there was
so we wanted to start with maybe pink
one protein
so let's search pink one protein
and see if we are finding something
and meanwhile as i was telling you that
you can find it here
and you can run this locally and i was
explaining you this in uh in summary the
docker image if you are here if you're
like listening to this for the first
time and you think these are like you
know very difficult uh keywords that i'm
using you need to go through the script
and
you'll be able to do this yourself
and if you're a program participant then
we can have a session for you to install
this
perhaps
uh so that's how you can do this locally
it's available here this link and now
let's go back
then we have this
to learn about the parameters and here
you start
start working on this and i'll share
again
the link in the chat
for you to
know
use this
now you start like this install
third-party software you have to just
just
do the play button just click here
and now you can see
sorry
this warning is coming
run anyways i'll do that
here you have to maybe use your google
login if uh to run this uh
once you are logged in you'll be able to
run
run this
and this is now installing in this
cloud notebook
collab notebook uh the softwares and you
can see what software is installing so
you can check the code here
and you can see that it's going to
install openmm pdb fixer
by 3d mall
and then uh
hummer
and it's just going to set the path all
of those things that you usually do
when you are running this so this is the
first thing you do is that
you run the uh
the third-party softwares and then you
download alpha fold and then you insert
the sequence now we want to look at the
sequence and
we will be
looking at that pink one protein so the
pink one protein comes up as a pink one
kinase so it's a kinase
now
let's go to uniprot from here we can
take you know take a look there and we
can open this entry as well to learn
more about the prediction
um
here
this is the sequence and this is the
predicted structure
now you can as i was telling you this
before
the
pldt score
and these are the different confidence
scores someone asked that question that
how do you value it so these are
different scoring that the software
provides
when you have predicted the alpha fold
these are the things that are going to
come up
and uh based on the sequence so i was
telling you that in a protein many
regions are like this loop region just
unstructured
the reason is that
from a structural biology perspective is
that that these regions are
flexible
so even in extra crystallography
sometimes many times these decisions are
not being able to traced we are not able
to trace them because they are
unstructured and they are flexible in
nature they move quite a lot
and
that's the reason the accuracy dips
here but there are also other regions
where the accuracy is known such as this
helix region
which is low and this is very low uh
this
orange region and i zoom in
here you will see so why that this is
very low and why this is high
is something that
can uh that we can uh maybe
uh predict or
think of based on the
available um based on the available
crystal structures that are there now uh
let's do that
to understand that
this protein with this structs this
sequence and this this is how the
protein is kind of folding through alpha
fold
and what are the different um
what are the different
structures experimentally available
with which are closer to the sprut pink
one kinase
which is what we are taking as first
example
uh
which
i think uh
punk it's shared right
now um uh we go to uniprot
and in the uni product it's important to
go to uniprot because in uniprot you
will be able to
find a lot of other information also
which is about the phenotypic
characteristics which is about the
function
and if it is involved in if this protein
is involved somewhere in alzheimer's
then you will be seeing related pathways
and such annotation if it provided it
that it is well and updated now the more
the annotation is
really good in this region only but not
the entire protein this is a big protein
with 612 like fairly big protein with
612 residues
now this portion is well annotated
because there might be crystal
structures available or some other
structures which came in maybe in
different organism maybe in different
maybe in different
uh
similar proteins which are also kinases
but not the same kind it could be like
same many things here you will see that
the annotation in terms of
function
and all this information you will find
and it also connects with as i was
telling you that this is directly
connected with alpha 4 and
one thing you should be doing is that
fine like there are two things
you have as i was telling you in the
presentation there are two things first
you check on pdb if the structure is
available or not then you check on alpha
4 database whether the structure is
available or not because that kind of uh
eases your uh like your your structure
is already predicted and you can use
that file directly for going doing the
downstream analysis you don't have to go
to that step and you can cite this so
it's a good practice that's why
uh i'm suggesting so now um as we were
here now we can download this structure
let's download this structure
this is the same place that we got when
we were here like it's the same same
place
so you can go from this uniprot id and
you can directly also search this data
database now what we want to do
is download the pdb file protein
databank file which is what we are going
to visualize in this session
all right
now we have downloaded the file we have
the sequence and uh what we wanted to
look at is also the sequence and then
check whether
how much of this is you know
experimentally known uh
maybe homologs or something like that so
what we are going to do now is that we
copied this sequence we got the sequence
from uniprot please uh
note that and then uh we also have the
predicted structure from alpha how do we
predict the structure we we simply take
these steps
we
we take step one when what we did we
take uh we installed the third party
softwares
then what we did we downloaded alpha
fold so let's download that this is the
next step it's getting downloaded and
then we are trying to make a prediction
but with already predicted alpha forward
structure we have also seen that how the
model is looking what are the confidence
levels of this model and we have
downloaded the structure and also the
sequence
so we have also got the sequence uh like
this and i've copied this sequence like
this
now what i want to do is to know
if this sequence is crystallized or part
of it is crystallized other homologs or
not so
i am going to do blast
eat
protein blast
in on ccpi
just
google protein plus pncpn and you'll get
here
and i think many of you are pretty much
worst with this and
know know about this but for those who
don't i'm just showing them how to do
this
so you uh have now
pasted your query sequence here now what
you have to do differently here is just
that change the database just use
protein databank now what it will do is
that it will search your sequence
against the protein data bank and
suggest us
if the structures are crystallized or
not so this is
to do uh
um
searching for
sequences that are uh experimentally
derived or not is the structure is if
experimentally derived or not now the
second thing you would want to do is
um
do the uh know if the structure is
experiment if predicted or not and how
do we do that i'm going to come to that
so protein
structure
now protein sequence similarity i think
it will get me to ebi
[Music]
this is the one
because i was telling you that ebi and
ebi embl and
deep mind has a collaboration
and they have deposited that's why you
can see those structures on uniprot
so you can perhaps
search
in epi
also the predicted structures from alpha
fold so
second
part of the analysis the first part was
to look at the experimental structures
the second part was to look at the
predicted structure so you know now both
the ways you learned how to do it i'll
show you how to do it in for predicting
for finding these is just like this
i'm again gonna share this link with you
all on the chat
so that
if you want you can try this
now or later
all right so we have both both the
things actually we have three things
going on
one is alpha fold
predictions and this is downloaded now
you can paste the sequence here also
and then
we have this uh
this blast going on we will know what
experimental structures are there and
then we are going to search for the
uh
for the predicted structures
here in this
in this
in this panel you will find alpha fold
db
now this is what you have to check
and here you want to paste your sequence
sorry
the sequence is
here
so i'll paste the pink one sequence and
obviously you can do it for your protein
i'm just giving this as an example
and the session is also getting recorded
so those participants will get the
recording and they can later try this on
out with their own
sequence of interest
and also connect with us to help
for helping
now
now you have selected this and you you
have selected structure
uh repository and you can search uh with
these uh parameters and you can get a
notification by email if it is going to
take time now i'll submit this
and we also it's still ongoing this
is a large protein as i was telling
comparatively 600 residues so it's going
to take some time
now coming back to alpha fold
now the structure you have download now
let's download the structure now we have
already downloaded this structure
now let's open the structure in chimera
and visualize this protein and do
protein structures
alignment
because that's what we wanted to also do
[Music]
sorry
so i'll search for chimera i have it
installed if you do if you have not
installed chimera i'll show you how it
is done
you just simply write chimera ucsf
and then you'll have the download
chimera page also the home page
in here you go and download the
windows version if you're on windows you
can download the mac version or the
linux version whichever version
is suitable for your system now after
downloading you need to install it by
simply going through the instruction
which are written here
so i've already installed it and it is
right here
so
the latest version is 1.16 and i think
i've installed the 1.16 version
but i also might have the older version
which i've forgotten to uninstall
so i'll check for that
the latest version
here
i have the
1.16 version so i'm opening i'm opening
this
and now we kind of downloaded that file
right from alpha fold we did downloaded
that by clicking
here
and the file is downloaded
here
i think now this one
all right so if i double click this will
open in pymol because my
my go to software is that but uh
both of them are equally good
so you just open this
like this
i mean you have to go to the path where
this is
kept
so
[Music]
i'll have to go to the downloads
here
now
maybe it's in the work folder i'll just
cut and paste it in the download folder
so that i find it easily
now i'll be able to find it here
maybe it requires a refresh
right got it here
now i'll double click and open this now
this is open in
ucsf chimera
which is what we want to learn today
and
this is the structure predicted
structure of pink one kinase
and this is a full-length structure
prediction
so
although i have to tell you this that
as it seems
this protein have some important uh um
structural components which are here and
looks like it will also have a binding
site here and that's based on my
experience but obviously once you look
at a
surface representation you will be able
to see that and we can perhaps do that
let's do that so that we all know the
it might take a while
okay this is like this
now you see that there are grooves
if you zoom in you'll find that there
are grooves
there are tunnels and there are places
uh where there could be like in binding
now why am showing this that this region
which is like the full-length region
might not be involved in the specific uh
specific uh
challenge that you're looking at maybe
you're targeting this protein
you maybe are inhibiting this protein
and there's a ligand here where you can
bind this in inhibit and you might not
need this region
so many times as a computational
structured biologist or maybe a chem
informatics person
you will not be worried about the full
structure you are more uh focused on a
specific
area of the structure which is well
predicted and which is uh kind enough
has more information
so let's go back to ribbon
representation again this is the ribbon
representation
uh to check look at clearly and do a
super imposition i am waiting for the
results from um
ncbi blast to do the
alignment
now this is important information here
you see
it's a civilian protein kinase pink one
putatif where structure is known
and
um this is the organism
uh
[Music]
and this is the score and this is the
query coverage means that 79 of the
alignment is covered which is a good
overall good uh coverage not bad
and then the identity is 54 these are
two parameters
that you should be taking a look at
obviously other parameters are important
as well but these two parameters tells
you a lot about the alignment because
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to align your sequence
uh which is what we pasted from here
to the sequences which are available on
pdb like crystal structures or um
nmr structures or
cryo em structures and henceforth
three things to note here two things i
two things uh two couple of things which
is one is query coverage and percentage
identity third is this accession code
now let's take a look at uh look at this
um
look at this alignment in much more
detail so if you click
all right
it'll show it will take you to
this
down below from here or it will expand
this and you can check the alignment
this typical blast
you will see that
how the alignment is this is like
you know as we saw here this is uh
this is 79 coverage and 54 percent
identity
with this uh pdb id
7t 4k
now let's download this pdp
and compare this with the predicted
structure this is the closest structure
and we have a predicted one and we want
to compare both of them
that's the alignment part and they were
questions and that's where we want to
use this ah
there's a question from
dixie can i use auto doc vienna or any
other visualization tool i cannot seem
to download
kymer so auto doc vienna is not exactly
a visualization tool but you can
definitely use
pymol i'm going to show it right now
this is going to you this is another
visualization and i'm going to double
click as this is my default software
so this is
primal so you can try primal
this is action
show height level color i'll show
cartoon
just
this way you are being able to take a
look at cartoon and in the time in the
in the
chimera software i also showed you the
surface visualization so here also i'll
show you the surface visualization
um
surface
now you can see the surface and
obviously you can change the color
um
like this and you can also check the
hydrophobic opacity surface like this
so yeah i'm similarly i showed you two
softwares one is chimera one is another
primer do similar things
and uh maybe i'll come back and again
show you
how to do alignment in pi m1 but let me
show you this first in chimera
now where were we we wanted to download
this structure
74k
now i can directly write it like that on
google and it will give me the right
entry but i'll show you both ways
um
sorry
now this is 74k
70
4k and enter
it will directly take me to the
this this is a unique id but again now
you can go to pdb
sometimes you don't get like sometimes
it's a common
for that reward
that might
give you multiple resistors
so you can search here as well you can
directly search here or you can search
uh
they search uh directly
write it like this which i showed you
earlier and it will take you directly to
the link so
this is
the link to the experimental structure
which is what we want to download
now let's also if we are having time
let's take a look at this is done
[Music]
now
this is a very big protein so maybe we
will just use
some part of it
and we'll get the similar structure
because it's uh we are downloaded
already this structure but we are still
doing a prediction
now in the prediction part when you are
trying to predict you can incorporate a
mutation or a couple of mutation you can
change aspartate to you know
uh to alanine this is a alanine mutation
so you can do these things and generate
a structure of the mutant variant
just to compare and see where this
position of amino acid is in the
structure
and then you can do further analysis and
maybe we will do a session on mutation
especially and i'm going to work with
sarah as well and then we are going to
do a session on mutations because i
think it's uh it's quite relevant uh now
this is
this is done it has
it
has kind of
edit the file and then search against
generic genetic databases and then i'll
run the alpha for prediction it's kind
of simple and then you can download the
results also it kind of provides that
after the run so here you can
see all of those uh
queries and all of that i think i you
have the link and please feel free to go
and do your predictions and reach out to
us if you face any trouble
now um
yeah swasti there is is there a limit
yes there is a limit uh there is a limit
uh of alpha fold prediction i think
thousand some residues uh for uh
for the online version but i will check
and get back to you for
this
for
the fourth thousand five hundred and
thirty six i mean
it's a huge protein um i mean it must be
interesting but yes uh maybe we can take
a look at it and uh
and let you know if we can do a
prediction which could be done locally
because obviously this cannot be done on
the server
but it could be i think done locally and
like as i was telling you that you could
use multiple softwares as well now um
this was alpha four please feel free to
run and do this now we will go back to
the result analysis of all four results
and uh we will download this structure
structure of dimeric uh phosphorylated
uh ridiculous humanness
take one uh with king alpha c helix in
chain b so there are two chains in this
and this is done through
electron microscopy
uh resolution is uh decent
and
then uh if if you are working on this
it's highly recommended that this is a
very recent reason paper this just came
in 2022 and in nature high impact
journal
uh activation mechanism i think it's a
must read for those who are working on
this so this is the way and now download
this file
let's download it now let's open this up
in chimera
all right
just
cut this
file and put it in my working folder so
that is of excess access and also like
we'll open it in primo also because
someone had some trouble with chimera so
that we know two softwares
all right so now if you see this is a
separate uh uh protein there are two
proteins now they're they're not aligned
and this is the crystal structure this
is the model protein
with uh the the similarity is also like
around
56 or something like this
but obviously what we are trying to do
here is to compare the structure not the
sequence you saw that sequence
similarity
scores in blast and you can do multiple
sequence alignment during using cluster
crystal omega and all of that to get
more statistics or do a secondary
structure prediction and all of that but
uh what we are trying to do here is
three dimensional structure comparison
uh which was the part of this uh
um
this workshop now uh let's uh do this
here as well
this is
loaded
i guess so
yeah here
now you have two proteins on the screen
and you want to align these two proteins
and no statistics wise that how closely
they are aligned
and uh if this protein one of the
objective of alignment is
also then
you will be able to find the active site
in the predicted protein
those are some of the applications in
time
what do you would want to do and
if you want to do the
if you want to do the alignment you have
to go to tools
structural analysis
you'll find different tools that can
give you different uh
analysis like finding the hydrogen bonds
and like putting them up and all
structure comparison
and there are different these different
utilities that you can check out and
maybe try them up
because it's kind of gives insights but
what we are going to use now is
matchmaker
matchmaker is an alignment tool
and in matchmaker you have options to
change all of this and if obviously if
you are aware of
aware of these you can change the
algorithm to neutral and munch and smith
waterman many of you who have taken
bioinformatics would have learned about
the the
the substitution matrices all of that
but we are not going to change anything
because we are going to do a default
setting which is mostly suitable for
most of the problems
now what we want to do
our reference structure here it is an
important aspect our reference structure
is the crystal structure
our structure that i we want to match is
the
predicted structure so i've selected
earlier both of them were selected i
selected this this is a selection this
is reference structure this is structure
to match you can change that you can
keep this as a reference structure and
this is structured to match but
as this crystal structure and this is
the predictor structure so we are using
the structure as the reference structure
now i'll just say apply and then it'll
align these
so i've applied and it's computing and
it's going to align these structures now
it has aligned the structure now you see
this is the predicted structure
versus
the
and this is chain b
so this is additional
but you can see that
how the other part of the chain is
interacting which was not there in your
predicted structure
now how can you see which one is which
because i think you're getting confused
so let me do this
and we are done with the matchmaker this
is a model panel
you can choose whichever you want to
visualize
this is your crystal structure
and this is your model structure
you see there are some regions
which are
now you can see that site this this part
of the interaction because you compared
it with a crystal structure now you can
do several of such comparison energy is
required to do such comparisons and how
can you do these several comparisons you
can simply refer
to your blast results here you will see
that there are multiple structures that
have come up not just one many
so you can find out do some comparison
which are closely related up to fifty
percent maybe
take these seven eight structures or
maybe they may many of them are like
copies
so maybe three four structures you will
get and you will do a comparison
that will be a good image for your
publication or your report that first
image
all right so this is how you do it now
statistic statistics wise
when you run this there is a console
okay
so
chimera
[Music]
command line
you can also use command line to do some
of the selections
and
reply log
so you have to click on reply log
and it will tell you the statistics
so the statistics it's going to give you
is something like this
so this is the value that you have to
report in the paper publication or
elsewhere or wherever like you're
showing this that
these many atoms aligned
from each amino acid and this is the
rmst
now rmst
of
0.844 means that these structures are
close very close because rmsd of one
is also like considered to be close when
there is an higher rmsd 3 4 2 5 6 then
it says like the structures are
dissimilar from each other like getting
more and more disciplined so it's a good
alignment that you've got because it's a
good uh
good um rfsd value
0.084 which is less than one which is
considered to be good rms value and you
can keep this to gain on talk about the
structure which is compared by with
another structure
so that's the structure comparison part
and that's the allah that's the
statistical part and that's how you use
chimera structure prediction i hope that
we covered a lot of things in today's
session
now i'm going to quickly show you how do
you do this on using time mall which is
again very simple
so uh
hide everything
show cartoon we have two cartoon
representation of two proteins
now here i'll there are two tabs
you can choose
like you can deselect select like this
this is let's see look like this
now i want to align this protein which
is the predicted one af a0836
to t
74k
so i'll align
this protein into the
crystal structure
this protein into the crystal structure
so
af you see where i'm clicking i'm
clicking in front of af and i'm clicking
the a button because a is action from
action we'll find different options
in the action you'll find a line
then you can align to just a selection
but you can align to the entire molecule
now 74k
this has a different alignment you see
this uh
this is
the alignment that we got from pi mall
which is also a decent alignment but you
can see
let's check out the rmsd
so the rmsd here what we have got and
you will get it in this panel is 347
atoms
at
0.801 so you've got two
comparative results one from chimera
chimera gave us how much
okay
reply log
gave us
0.844
between 362 atoms
and pi mole gave us
less atoms on a better rmst
so that's the way to compare structures
and to report rmsd using multiple
softwares and we learned about chimera
we learned about pymol we'll learn about
alpha fold and
i think we covered different aspects i
hope that um
this is helpful for many of you since
alpha predictions are based on
christopher you can use the solution
structure no alpha phone predictions are
not based on crystal structure swathi
alpha four predictions are based on
experimental structures which includes
nmr and all whichever whichever is
present on pdb so it's not
uh only on crystal structures
so um the next question please the pdb
code of the second protein 74k
if you want to take this example i'll
just share the
files here no we just have it here
74k i'll just
take a look
at this
file
and
uh and you can download this file
and
replicate exactly the same thing that we
did so i'm sharing all these files in
the chat
please save them and then try on your
own
um
i think that's all from my part today
and if we have dr puneet then i'll pass
this back to sri gauri
to take this further
all right thank you so much sir so to
start with the next part of today's
workshop which is the q a session i'm
delighted to invite dr puneet kaka
having a phd in drug discovery from
university of geneva he is a strong
advocator for using advanced technology
in pharmaceutical research and
development with that i would like to
invite dr bonit kaka to start with the q
a session
so we have a
couple of queries uh
is it necessary to report findings from
different softwares
okay if i can take that up
[Music]
yeah i mean you don't need to report
findings from different softwares it's
not necessary you can report one
software uh which is so either you know
by mall chimera if you're doing a
comparative study then you want to
compare
and then report different software so
there are benchmarking publications and
all uh studies where you would want to
do that and then there are
mechanical mechanistic or translational
studies where you don't have to do that
all right uh i hope that answered you
query
yes so i have also received few personal
questions uh i used alpha 4 to predict
the structure of a protein that has not
been well studied i have a pdb file of
the predicted structure
now i would like to identify the domains
of the protein using this pdb file is
there a suitable tool for my purpose
what we did today i think you should be
able to do that i mean first of all get
that information from the experimental
structures if there are any
and if not then yes i mean we saw that
on uniprot that the function of the
proteins are discussed in the context of
the residue so if it is a well annotated
protein you will also find variants and
all that information just on uniprot so
with that information you can annotate
and characterize your protein structure
or you can use other structures which
are
which are uh similar structures which we
did today
all right so thank you so much uh
punitsa and we also have another
question please i wish to know how the
active site and the residues of the
active site of a protein can be found
also how to attach ligands and cofactors
to alpha fold predicted structures
okay so after website uh prediction
there are many tools which are also
available for active site prediction but
um
what we are looking at is that
uh in active site uh there are
characterized active sites so to unfind
characterize active sites you can do
structural comparison and find such
active sites and also find
co-crystallized
or cool
bound
cofactors or ligands based on comparing
with other structures which has a
similar form which is through the alpha
fold repository or through the pdb
repository two ways you can do that
another aspect of doing this is to you
know take a look at this
solvent accessibility surface area and
all of that which is like taking a look
at the surface and understanding what
are the different tunnels and hosts uh
and of course uh where that you can do
also using pdb sums so pdb summaries are
cool
which are present in your protein
uh all right sir so there is also a
question are there any applications to
use alpha four beyond structure
prediction
uh sorry can you repeat that question
yes sir are there any applications to
use alpha fold beyond structure
prediction
yeah i was telling you know
we have kind of discussed this that uh
what we can do is with that
initial information we can
try we will try
[Music]
this can be like based on the structure
there are
several dynamics analysis that one would
be likely more likely to do that how
these molecules behave in motion
so yeah i mean there are a lot of things
one can do but like for structure
prediction uh alpha fold is one of the
tools but using uh alpha fold i think uh
there are now uh pymol scripts uh sorry
python scripts for uh multimers and
there are advanced tools for protein
protein protection complexes also alpha
volt is getting used and in the advanced
tutorials you'll be able to find them
those applications as well as well as as
i was telling you that um
for cancer studies and mutations this is
an important tool
uh all right so thank you so much and
there is uh another question
could you help me i generated the
predicted structure protein by using
alpha four two my question how to
identify the transmembrane domain and
transmembrane helices
okay
[Music]
so you're reading this i'm currently
working on p450 enzymes that's that's
the one
uh
it says uh i generated the predictive
structure protein by using alpha for two
okay and
my question is how to identify the
transmembrane domain and transmembrane
yeah you can predict the transmembrane
domain and transmembrane helices there
are softwares you can simply uh use them
uh to predict that and transmembrane uh
domains and helices have have a special
characteristics based on the amino acids
that they hold
those features of amino acids so based
on that there are predictions and the
secondary structure prediction tools
they
i think um
hammer has a transmembrane prediction
software and usually the transmembrane
sites are like big helices uh in size
and they pass through the membrane uh
and uh you can take a look at the
crystallized recently crystallized
transmembrane helices and also like i
would recommend all of you to do one
thing for sure is to do a structural
comparison like thorough structural
comparison when you simply do structural
comparison you annotate all these
because uh what all of these tools are
relying on is uh they are relying on the
experimental data so if there is
experimental data to correlate with why
not do that because that will give you
give us the answers
all right sir uh and then punitsa and we
also have a few more questions so in a
situation where there are no
experimental structure and the predicted
structure for a protein sequence from
alpha-4 did not meet the expected
quality how should one proceed
okay when there is uh
not much available on experimental
structure it's become very um you know
it becomes uh
it's difficult to validate perhaps it's
it's
even if you are predicting correctly you
are not sure if your predictions are
going to work or not unless there is a
wetlab validation so that's what i have
i have uh kind of understood and like
realized during my phd also for those
proteins where the structures are not at
all possible to build people use abby
issue methods
and then there are
methods where you can
think of you know folding that protein
from the very basic sequence that would
require maybe you know microseconds of
simulations so
those are different ways like either you
try to fold it using simulation
and run a very long simulation if it is
a small size protein that is that is
still doable
to through simulation long-range
simulation
uh and also through ab initio modeling
but if only if it is a small size
protein because if it's a big size
protein then these are very complex
steps which are usually not viable and
again the problem is validation because
when you're going to publish or you want
to write about it the questions uh
would be about the
correctness of this and
there has to be either uh wet lab
studies where you're mutating and
showing that this this is the effect and
this is the correct model otherwise
there are evidential models that are
predicted uh being published but uh
reliability wise it's difficult for the
community to
just rely on that unless there is some
wet lab experiments to support that
all right so thank you so much and uh
i think we could pass on the questions
to punisher as well could you make him
the co-host
uh there are a few more questions
i am the whole
um
yes sir yes
okay
yes sir
let me do that just a second
all right sure
so if the participants are having any
further queries please put in the chat
the meanwhile we will answer the ones
that have been put in the chat box
you dr mohamed thank you very much thank
you
my disciplines
yeah may i know the question please
all right sir thank you so much uh the
question is what is the thermodynamics
behind the ligand protein interaction
okay so thermodynamics study uh
can be done
in a lot of ways and
more important is to understand the
kinetics of it
the critical part of understanding the
uh
leaking protein interaction is its
residence time
so consider that you are developing a
non-covalent inhibitor for a protein of
your interest
and you wanted to understand that how
your molecule is going to behave
once it is binding to the binding site
of the protein or the target of princess
now how much time is compound in drugs
interacts remain in the binding site and
also important consideration and all
those considerations comes from the
uh
from the
kinetic studies of
protein median interactions
also
when you are doing molecular dynamic
simulations everything
uh a lot many methods
actually require thermodynamics to see
binding and unbinding of the ligand so
very important aspects and without that
without understanding of the
thermodynamics and how it is being used
in simulations ligand binding
interactions
would be very difficult
all right so thank you so much and the
next question is i'm currently working
on p450 enzymes that use heme as
cofactor please how can this be attached
to the predicted structure of the p450
for downstream analysis
okay i think it's a very good question
so when we perform molecular modeling
exercise
no matter what method do we use for
prediction of the structures three
dimensional structures particularly
of the proteins of interest the problem
is uh how do we
locate our
um
oh
the
most appropriate uh step would be
to perform the structure superimposition
with the most similar protein
because in such cases wherever the
cofactors are bound especially the heme
the site around the
cofactor remains conserved
so idea here is to perform the selected
superimposition if the overall super
simple position of the protein is not
great
align them
from the experimental structures try to
um uh replace the coordinates
and then
if possible do some some minimization
steps i think that should be sufficient
just to optimize the interactions with
the surrounding residues and that should
be
that should be fine
all right i hope that answered your
query and then next question is how does
alpha 4 deal with multi-domain proteins
and what is a good approach predicting
for separate problems or predicting as a
whole
okay so good question i think in
molecular modeling again this is
challenges for the multiple multiple
quaternary structures of the protein
where you have multiple sequences
multiple
they are non
uh so i guess you can mute it okay
predict the individual
predict the individual uh protein
structures
understand how these proteins start
individual protein sequences all the
structures interact with each other
whether they make any symmetry so these
kind of studies are generally published
in the literature
more similar sequences more similar
sequences and their structure would be
the ideal methodology how
the protein functions that is also
important
the class of protein where the multiple
domains are multiple sequence the
quaternary structure you are predicting
how do they function
um
how do they interact with each other
um what is the mechanism of action of
those proteins that you want to study
those kind of informations are generally
there in the
literature so basis that it's not
blindly relying on the
method of modeling itself but you need
to collate this information and build
your knowledge about the protein
and then individually model and do this
and do this modeling together
some commercial software they have the
ability to model the protein i believe
has this kind of suit available but of
course in those cases also they need a
princess structure in any way
so the best approach is to understand
to know more about the protein
consider your protein is the best body
we wanted to know more about it
as you know more i think you will be
able to
write the problem
all right sir then the question is i am
from a computer science background with
mathematics uh background as well and
wish to start with chem informatics will
this workshop be a good place to start
i think a lot
um
what is happening in the current
scenario is we need people who
understand both the things
those who are good in computers
understand algorithms understand
mathematics and also have the domain
knowledge
the amalgamation that the joint venture
of these two knowledge
things uh is is certainly very uh very
demanding in the market
and
it's very difficult to get the practical
hands-on available
in a systematic fashion so these kind of
workshops are very helpful just to
speed up
get up to the speed in terms of what is
uh what is what a general introduction
some hands-on where you can fit find
your the exact fit
what is interest to you most and those
things are
you know very very helpful in such a
short time you get lot many information
uh to work on so i strongly believe that
these kind of workshops are very useful
for
for anyone who is expert in one side of
the knowledge
all right so then another question is
i'm currently working on protein
alignment visualization i am confused
which to use alpha fold or alpha 4 2
okay so
um
whatever is the latest one you should
always go for this i don't think there
will be much of the difference but if
there are differences
think about
uh the accuracy level at the your
protein class level if there is any
so
go to the publication to see if they
have any done any classification on that
net opinion for proteases they are 95
percent
and but oxidase is like 80 because of
the less number of structures available
for example i'm just throwing the random
gas
now idea here is just to see but
even beyond using any algorithm as a
black proxy i strongly recommend you to
read about the complication if you are
not reading publication if you are not
understanding or you are not conceiving
your protein as a best body
it becomes very difficult for you to
justify or
justify them
you need to understand
in and out from pedal to the grave of
everything related to that protein
then it gives you a lot of fun and this
is how people build the skill
uh i expertise into one set of proteins
one set of molecules one set of
mechanism
one set of you know pathways
all like that
they spend huge amount of time of their
precious life and then they become
exposed
so
reading reading reading
is the
is the first thing in in science
especially of this science
and
and then you can choose
very
diligently or very carefully i would say
the the algorithms out there
thank you sir and the next question is
how reliable are the alpha four
predicted structures when uh there is no
experimental data available for that
routine can we use alpha 4 predicted
structures to run some simulations
okay so we use insect alpha 4 only when
the structures are not available
experiment so that's the first thing
then then only we are going for the
prediction there are some some
[Music]
some clauses for that for example your
complete protein size is more than what
is available in the experimental
structures right
so for example your protein is a
thousand amino acid long but this excess
structure is only for 500 but you are
interested in the other 500 which is
which does not have any any any
experimentally known structure in such
cases alpha code and other methods of
modeling would be very useful
but again it's very subjective
you read
understand how the host 500 is attached
to the second attach means how they are
connected to each other for example this
first 500 that you are seeing in the
experimental structure is extracellular
domain the other 500 which does not have
the structure experimentally known is
transmembrane or intracellular domain
then you need to see the reliability
because trans-membrane domains is
completely a prediction and not so many
proteins out there in the
in the pdp also to give alpha fold a
very good guess that what kind of
uh rota merge arrangements or the angle
should be ideally for for the amino acid
falling into these
into these brackets
so
the point is that if you
if you want to do a study but if you
don't have anything
it's better to to have something and
then begin this
so alpha 4 take alpha 4 like that
consider that if alpha fold is not there
you may be predicting with some very
rough estimated methods but since you
have some good assumption of how the
optimally
optimal arrangements of your miners
backbone and sidechain should be
you can take it from there
go for simulation if you really want to
dig into the more details then for some
simulations as dr muhit was also saying
in in earlier question
and then begin your study but
that's not the end of things
reading is the first thing that should
be in the center of it
then you then you will be able to answer
the the questions that you have framed
the hypothesis that you have in mind
while predicting instruction so it
should be the reading should be recycled
thank you so much sir that was really
inside insightful and then are there any
limitations to using alpha fold that i
need to be aware of if so what other
alternatives can i use
okay so alpha 4 again is number of from
ios its limitations we have already seen
other thing is the though
the
the binding legions the crystal attacks
they will the placement of water they
should not be very optimum for example
if you want to do some water bridging
exercise with your compound and how it
it facilitates the binding that kind of
study you cannot do
you can get the one screenshot of your
molecule of the of the protein but if
you want to do the dynamic nature of
this of the protein then you won't be
able to understand these are some of the
limitations that you need to think it
off you need to always take this one as
a pinch of salt in case your protein is
so unique it does not have any
similarity with the existing structures
in the data tank then again alpha 4 will
be a lot rough estimate
um
yeah these are couple of
issues that i can i can think it off or
i know at least
and
and again for
whatever the challenge is you have new
challenges which cannot be overcome by
alpha 4 but
i would say
don't even think alpha fold will be the
first of solution for all your problems
it's just one big step that can solve a
lot of problems that's correct
but there are more ways
it's not like all the problems are
solved
all medicine will be discovered
no
will be the disease anymore
and everything will be all right
unfortunately that's not the case so
these are not many things to study and
find the solutions for
all right sir the next question
give distance between the n and c
terminals as a distance restraint for a
domain that always opens up during
minimization runs
okay so if there is uh
there is some
bond which are getting opening up in the
in in some minimization it means that
they are not properly connected i
believe so
that should be the case or you are
choosing a wrong method of optimization
so i would say if you
if if you have done some
peptide building i guess
as a peptidomics make sure you clean the
geometry before doing the minimization
so that you understand that all the
points are properly connected
um
a simple step of steeper descent uh
conjugate gradient newton raphson would
work or simple energy minimization
should also help a clean up cleaning up
the geometry cleaning of the structure
would be the ideal step from 2d to 3d
structure transition
and i think that should solve the
problem i think the bonds are not
properly connected to each other
all right so so the next question is um
hello hello sir i have identified alpha
force structure predictions that might
not be in the database will i be able to
deposit as a student
um i guess if that is the case now i
think in all the sequences insist
i see alpha force
structures are available but in case you
do not
see your structure available
in alpha 4 then you need to make sure
yours your sequence is unique your
protein is you make
just try to search it against the class
key i will use blast key against the nr
database and then just brought unifraud
and see the ideal step would be to
deposit your sequence first into the
database
once your sequence gets submitted into
the database alpha 4 will automatically
picks up the
structure prediction exercise don't run
it if your protein is
really new
don't rush for alpha fold
brush rather rush for the
sequence submission because that will
give you a
better
better prospects in future
thank you so much sir and the final
question we have is can we use custom
database of protein structure with
alpha-4 would that be a valid approach
if i want to predict structures of
protein from same family of full type
so you want to if i understand you want
to train your
alpha code as a
you want to use your database to train
alpha code selectively
or maybe it's kind of using your
transfer learning for example
or you want to do some
okay if that is the case
i think the code is there
and you should be able to do it
but my point is that how big is it is
if you have for example all oxidatives
you just have all exercises
uh you compiled and made it and then you
wanted to be trained
and run for
a prediction of exclusive oxidation that
can be approached but i think that may
not be a very general one also
once you do it and you start publishing
these kind of things then make sure that
you do a thorough testing end to end
so check the results whatever are out
there whatever they have done a huge
exercise needs to be done
i would say if you are
doing particularly this exercise as your
phd work or some very cool
uh
you know
modeling stuff
then do it
if your
main objective is to uncover the
scientific
findings of what protein does what's the
function discover new compounds
then i would say keep that part little
aside and maybe you focus more on the
science part
rather than building the whole database
you can learn
get the get the phone on on your
database also
i think that's a little deviation
because that's completely computer
science part
and this is mostly on the scientific
side
so it depends on what what difference i
think that's impossible
if github code allows you
all right thank you so much sir so that
was the final question so if the
participants have any more questions
please put that in the chat box and
before wrapping up with the q a session
i would like to uh request punitsa to
share some thoughts on how one can make
the most out of the workshops you had
mentioned some points we'd like to add
on some more to these points on how
i think more most important points
is
research you want to spend a significant
amount of time of your life
for the topic
then certainly you will keep asking
questions discover new and new things
about your
maybe a molecule
disease or whatever
speaking of a disease is a very good
idea because it gives you a more
holistic
view of how you can how how to see the
diseases discovered what are the
components and what
in
in chem informatics if you have a
particular interest i would say you pick
up a disease of your interest
learn about it
get more
deeper into the disease mechanism
what does this what kind of drugs are
already discovered what are the
challenges and clinical trials why drugs
are failing
getting approved or
withdrawn from the market
why drugs are not so efficacious for
those indications
a lot of areas are there
i
think just start from one disease at a
time
and
open up your mind of
asking questions
more questions about you see more
questions
and cover holistic view of
the landscape of
how the drug discovery happens
once you do that kind of holistic view
coverage
i think in future you can
whatever is a disease i think you can
easily
be able to find or frame the solutions
this is what i think it should be but
liking for your subject and a
determination that i will spend really
good amount of time
of my life
would be the key step here
otherwise you will not keep asking
questions on
on the topic and you will not
build your knowledge
all right thank you so much sir it was
really great to have you here and we had
lots of queries from the participants
and it was a really interactive session
as well so
thank you to all the participants as
well for your patience and the video
recordings of today's workshop will be
mailed to you and if you have any
further queries you can reach out to the
con
email id that i've provided in the chat
and the contact number so for that
it's a wrap up for today's workshop and
thank you so much and have a great day
thank you
thank you very much everyone
thank you bye-bye
bye sir
you